it's so incredible to have you know how
this all ends you and a handful of
people know how this whole thing ends
that has gripped the planet and there
aren't many episodes left what's it like
that you have this information in your
brain that you're carrying around that
people desperately want you have it it's
kind of terrifying I can remember when I
saw it first got the email through
saying here are your season 8 scripts it
was like I don't know if I want to read
these I don't really want that in my
head it's like having government secrets
I can just people just send those out
these days you couldn't there's they're
so rare so chill now about that yeah but
yeah there was a lot of understandably a
huge amount of secrecy on set this year
because we've suffered leaks in the past
and we just really wanted to make sure
nothing got out so I can remember
like when I first when I first read them
I was still at college and I like double
lock the door stuck all the blinds so I
was like this is quite valuable property
to students then quite like today the
end of game of thrones and then when I
told my mum the ending I was on the
phone I was like I can't the phone could
be tapped I'll have to tell you a person
that was the level of paranoia that were
you allowed to tell your mother well I
did we got her liquored up and she's
here tonight
[Applause]